faut qu'on parle ouais là je pense qu'il
faut vraiment qu'on parle donc je suis
tout simplement choqués assez abasourdi
il ya vraiment plein d'infos je sens que
je vais regretter de faire encore une
petite critique à chaud comme je le fais
des fois par moments pour les gros films
comme
avengers ou star wars je les réserve
maintenant pour les gros films vraiment
qu'ils me chamboule les grosses licences
et là je pense vraiment que ça mérite
une petite critique fin pas une critique
mais une réaction en fait un avis à
chaud en fait comme j'aime bien le faire
par moments
j'aime bien exprimer mon avis mon
ressenti donc là il est actuellement
1h25 du matin je suis sorti de la séance
il ya environ trente minutes je suis
rentré chez moi y'a 30 minutes
les animaux fantastiques de les crimes
de grindelwald alors je vous avoue que
j'ai pas trop quoi dire en premier parce
que en même temps je ne sais pas quoi
dire j'ai trop rien à dire en fait et en
même temps il ya tellement de choses
j'ai tellement de choses dans ma tête
j'ai tellement de choses que j'ai envie
de dire c'est assez troublant
tout d'abord on va parler assez
générales en fait visuellement le film
était très beau franchement c'était
magnifique surtout la scène du début
avec alors oui ce sera une une réaction
avec spoiler évidemment je j'ai plus
envie de faire du sans spoiler je trouve
ça vraiment sans intérêt
ce sera vraiment avec spoiler donc je
vous alerte maintenant avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard
donc oui le film est vraiment très très
beau visuellement genre surtout la scène
du début de la pourchasse avec
grindelwald est vraiment magnifique
j'avais même un petit peu peur pour les
épileptiques parce que il y avait pas
mal de flash de lumière je trouvais avec
les éclairs mais nan franchement c'est
le film était vraiment d'une beauté
visuelle mais vraiment je trouve ça
incroyable
en plus c'était à paris cité chez nous
le petit père lachaise maintenant en
termes d'acteurs donc je les connais pas
tous surtout deux noms mais jude law est
parfait en deux meules d'or johnny depp
est parfait en grindelwald nord vers
dragonage ou très bien je connais plus
son nom j'ai oublié son nom d'acteur
puis croyants c'est pareil ezra miller
il joue très très bien enfin tout le
monde joue vraiment très bien fait j'ai
pas trouvé vraiment de deux défauts ou
aux 2 le film était vraiment parfait je
trouve le seul défaut que j'ai trouvé un
petit peu au film ses quelques petites
longueurs voilà de temps en temps
surtout au début en fait parce que c'est
une histoire qui se raconte vraiment
tout sur la fin en fait tout se repose
sur la fin c'est que de l'espérance tout
sur la fin et du coup le début j'avoue
que la première heure je l' ai senti un
petit peu passées en fait chez un petit
peu vu le temps passer et ça donne en
général c'est pas trop bon signe mais
c'est vraiment un tout petit défaut
parce que j'ai vraiment trouvé film
vraiment très très bien est vraiment
excellent je suis content parce que
c'est à peu près vraiment ce que
j'imaginais c'est clair on rentre
vraiment dans le vif du sujet beaucoup
critiquent un peu d'animaux fantastiques
où s est un peu à l'eau d'euros c'est
cool et c'est assez tranquille c'est des
nouveaux animaux etc
les animaux fantastiques les créatures
magiques et tout mais non ça servait à
poser le contexte a présenté drague ono
a présenté un petit peu
grindelwald en m lemaitre le personnage
en suspens pour la suite ça va rien trop
raconté son histoire l'appui mettre en
avant croyances racontait le contexte
raconter vraiment le début l'origine les
obscurs yeux c'était un rack est ce que
c'est ça servait vraiment à ça à mettre
les bases a posé les bases on est sur
une saga quand même de cinq films car
faut toujours tu viennes m'emmerder on
est quand même sur une saga de cinq
films donc il ya du temps on va dire
pour le développement on n'est pas sur
une simple trilogie comme star wars ou
faut vraiment tout bouclé ou faut
vraiment que ce soit un résumé en deux
heures qui est tout raconter en 6h quoi
là on est quand même sur siph cinq films
pardon de
plus de deux heures donc on est quand
même à 10 heures deux scénarios donc on
est beaucoup plus souple fin il ya
beaucoup plus de souplesse et beaucoup
plus ample donc on peut mieux
appréhender la chose quoi donc le film
un servait vraiment à ça là le film the
wrong rentre vraiment dans le vif du
sujet dumbledore et grindelwald les
personnages clés les personnages
principaux avec norbert dragon's haut et
puis croyances du coup le personnage de
galère de greendale valdes est vraiment
je trouve hyper intéressant franchement
il est il est parfait quoi donc oui si
une représentation un petit peu de la
seconde guerre mondiale de chez les
moldus en gros c'est vraiment un petit
peu le le adolphe on va dire des
sorciers et franchement je trouve qu' il
est parfait en fait parce que du coup on
ne sait jamais ce qui est vrai ce qui
est faux c'est un manipulateur très
puissant genre on a l'exemple parfait
avec queen i georges adoré le fait que
queen y retourne sa veste
alors que normalement c'est 'qui nick
est censé lire dans les pensées des gens
là c'est comme si c'était gai laërt qui
avaient mieux les pensées de queen et
qui du coup la contrôler un petit peu
techniquement puisqu'il réussit à la
séduire à la manipuler alors c'est censé
être elle qui a ce pouvoir en gros c'est
ce genre de détails qui est vraiment
hyper appréciable et franchement le
personnage de green day valdes est
vraiment excellent mais comme le
personnage de dumbledore mail un petit
peu mis en retrait pour certainement les
autres films en fait la sté vraiment
pour mettre en avant grindelwald le
présenter et
montrer toute sa puissance toute cette
manipulation etc
j'avais peur un petit peu quand même pas
de fin j'avais pas forcément peur de la
déception parce que pour moi c'était
vraiment celui là le premier film en
fait les animaux fantastiques
1 et c'est un petit peu genre le film
zéro c'est là où on met tous et c'est en
pose les bases et j'avais peur un peu
parce que souvent les deuxièmes films la
suite le deuxième film et est souvent un
peu moyen je pense à star wars
même la saga harry potter ou autre
souvent je les trouve un petit peu moyen
quoi un petit peu en dessous du 1 est un
petit peu en dessous du troisième
tout simplement parce qu'on est sur une
saga en fait de plusieurs films de
vraiment pas mal de films là cinq films
du coup le deuxième c'est un petit peu
on va dire de péripéties normalement en
fait genre c il est là mais en même
temps il raconte pas des choses ouf
mais enfin ils racontent pas grand chose
quoi ces séjours un petit peu le périple
du héros quoi et genre souvent le sait
comme star wars 8 en fait je vois la
star wars cette pose les bases star wars
8 voilà ces machins et une histoire etc
et la star wars neuf c'est la conclusion
c'est le moment final l'affrontement et
c'est là c'est un petit peu pareil et
surtout que là on n'est pas encore dans
le plein plein coeur de l'histoire on
n'est qu'au deuxième film sur cinq
donc j'avais un petit peu peur de ça
mais au final j'ai vraiment pas été déçu
et je suis vraiment très très content de
ce que de ce qu'ils nous ont proposé jk
rowling maîtrise tout d'une main de
maître
c'est la noce de harry potter j'aurais
l'a vraiment gamme infinie selatan
hausse elles prévoient tout même le dr
strange
il faut que j'arrête les comparaisons
que star wars et marvel mais j'aime bien
me référer à ce que je connais bon on va
parler de ce que vous attendez le plus
parce que je sais que en même temps vous
êtes là pour ça on en parlera il y aura
1 3 théorie il va y avoir trois théories
certainement cette semaine je vais tout
faire pour le faire cette semaine un
trois théories sur les animaux
fantastiques 2 et il ya vraiment
beaucoup de choses à dire
alors par où commencer déjà nagini donc
nagini c'est la théorie des fans qui a
été confirmée nagini est vraiment une
personne victime d'un mal et dictus qui
du coup elle va se transformer en
serpent au bout d'un moment et elle va
du coup elle va se lier à voldemort à un
moment c'est ça va être son plus grand
allié à voldemort
il n'y a pas de réponse on ne sait pas
c'est pas dit dans les livres ou autres
on ne sait pas on sait pas le passé
nagini et là je pense qu'il ya des
choses à théoriser théorisé dessus et
j'ai franchement j'ai pas encore
réfléchi beaucoup à la question et je
sais pas trop quoi dire encore là dessus
il y aura forcément voldemort dans les
films il y aura certainement elle va
elle va être encore là nagui niel va
être là dans le troisième film quatrième
une cinquième film c'est obligé qu'elle
soit encore là on est sur une saga de
cinq films qui se passent de 1926 à 1945
pourquoi 1945 parce que c'est l'année où
dumbledore et grindelwald se sont
affrontés ou d'hommes bol d'or a gagné
et cetera dans l'histoire de harry
potter
donc la conclusion finale sera forcément
en 45 du moins normalement c'est parce
qu'il prévoit aux autres ce que je pense
à ça mais là c'est on est seulement un
an après la donc on est en 27
si on doit aller jusqu'en 45 yahia du
times il ya du times s'agace de cinq
films sur dix-neuf années c'est beaucoup
quand même enfin c'est peu de films et
beaucoup d'années du coup nagini va
peut-être changer et c'est peut-être
qu'elle va mal vivre ça sa trahison de
croyance qu'il l'a laissée pour son
son fantasme personnel de savoir
vraiment qui il est et cetera avoir des
réponses et tous et surtout elle va
forcément elle nagini la présence d'un
guinea va introduire voldemort dans la
saga voldemort est né en 26 est né
durant la première le premier film des
animaux fantastiques
alors non du coup nagini ne peut pas
être là la mère de voldemort
à part si je me goure dans les dates
mais vu qu'on est en 27 ou 28 et que
voldemort est né en 26 c'est tout
bonnement impossible mais dans l'est à
partir du quatrième cinquième film
normalement serait dans les fins années
trente années 40 du coût 45 voldemort
sera déjà un bon adolescents quasiment
un adulte du coup va y avoir on verra le
développement du coût de la guinée on va
forcément le voir dans dans la saga
alors oui un petit truc que j'ai oublié
dire au début c'est que je suis très
content des messages du film je trouve
que le film a passé vraiment de message
des messages très beau déjà avec norbert
lui tout seul norbert c'est vraiment un
un passionné d'animaux il est vraiment
très dense au monde je me demande même
si les pins il a pas un petit peu
d'autisme je dis pas ça méchamment mais
il est vraiment dans son monde
passionnée par les animaux les créatures
et cetera
je me jeu dans son comportement etc
je me suis même demandé si personnage il
avait il n'était pas un petit peu comme
ça et du coup il aimait ça je les trouve
vraiment pas vraiment beaucoup à ce
genre norbert à lui tout seul voilà la
protection des animaux il est totalement
passionné par sa les créatures et c'est
tout le monde
à sa place dans le monde etc y'a pas de
personnes chez plus comment il dit ça il
n'ya pas créatures différentes mais
seulement des personnes ignorant tout
autre et puis pareil avec les cirques
on voit avec les sires qui considère
tous comme des monstres croyances mahi
dictus c'est vraiment des gros fumier
les mecs on peut le dire c'est vraiment
des gros fumer et je trouve que ça c'est
un beau message parce que c'est c'est
quelque chose qui me tient à coeur ça
les animaux tout ça et le cirque
je n'irai jamais voir un cirque de ma
vie et c'est ça franchement c'est une
belle dénonciation je troue et ils ont
très bien fait la chose je trouve que ça
il partage de beaux messages
maintenant parlons du cas de l'état
laisse tranche alors l'état les strange
du coup elle est morte c'est voilà elle
est morte et s'effectuer par grindelwald
sauf que il est dit que son frère est
mort noyé et qu' elle a survécu que
c'est la dernière enfants les strange je
crois normalement sauf que du coup il ya
une descendance en fait genre bellatrix
bellatrix lestrange etc alors faut que
je me renseigne plus un sujet pas envie
dire de bêtise j'ai pas envie que vous
ne tombiez dessus mais pour moi ça veut
dire que le frère de l'état les strange
est encore en vie du coup il va y avoir
certainement un rapport avec les blacks
du coup la famille de sirius black
puisque sérieuse black est le cousin de
bellatrix lestrange va forcément y avoir
un lien il va se passer quelque chose
enfin genre ça va être expliqué je suis
un petit peu perdu là dessus mais c'est
un mystère aussi qui n'est pas encore
résolu ça enfin pour finir j'aimerais
parler de croyance évidemment on va
parler de croyance alors je sais pas si
je vais tout vous dire parce qu'en même
temps je vais en garder pour ma vidéo
théorie gens parler vite fait je vais
énoncer les grands points mais je vais
pas plus détaillée que sa croyance
serait aurelius dumbledore
le quatrième enfant dumbledore un enfant
qui aurait était
presque assassiné fin genre par
dumbledore albus par le bus de mulder a
le bus aurait voulu tuer cet enfant si
mes souvenirs sont bons et c'est le
quatrième frère de enfin genre c'est le
quatrième enfant de la famille
dumbledore
d'après ce que nous dit grindelwald
alors j'ai pas trop envie de m'étendre
sur le sujet parce que comme je vous ai
dit je vais faire ma vidéo théorie mais
voilà c'est soit ça bouvet soit ça
bouleverse tout le harry potter game
parce que dans l'histoire il ya
seulement que trois enfants de
dumbledore abers à belfort temps
français albert forte en anglais albus
et ariana et là du coup il y aurait
aurelius très malin en plus de ce que
c'est un nom qui commence par un a aussi
comme tous les enfants de n'sele d'or
est ce un mensonge
raynal valdes est un très grand
manipulateur moi c'est ce que je pense
et je vous expliquerai pourquoi dans ma
vidéo aux théories que je vous inviterai
à voir évidemment soit il ya un rapport
avec arianna mariana est c'est une très
grande théorie j'en avais parlé dans ma
première vidéo théorie sur la saga des
animaux fantastiques à rihanna serait un
obscur yal en fait ce serait un obscur
russe non non elle est est un obscur yal
victimes donc c'est plus d'un obscur us
et du coup il y aurait un rapport
peut-être entre les deux et c'est si
c'est vrai c'est peut-être un mensonge
je ne dirai rien le problème étant que
il y a le phénix le phénix voilà un
phénix est censé se présenter face un
dumbledore chaque dumbledore un phénix
fin d'après ce qu'explique le film
et peut-être que ce serait le fils d'une
tante dumbledore ou autre que ce serait
le plus tôt un cousin mais pas forcément
un frère bref il ya vraiment grosse
matière a théorisé et ça chamboule tout
le game parce que aurelius dumbledore
n'existe pas même dans les livres je me
suis bien renseigné je connais vraiment
bien l'histoire de dumbledore aurelius
n'existe pas donc là s'il rajoute un
frère c'est à dire ce n'est pas dans les
livres il renverse vraiment où le harry
potter games je sais vraiment pas quoi
dire croyants c'est vraiment un point
des tonnes d'interrogations et je
m'attendais pas du tout à ce qu'il
devienne aussi important je pensais
vraiment qu'il était le point vraiment
culminant du premier film et pas qui
serait aussi important dans dans la
suite en fait est sûrement ces troubles
et je pense vraiment une manipulation de
grindelwald d'un mensonge mais en même
temps il ya le phénix jeu j'en parlerai
dans ma vidéo théorie vous en faites pas
mais il ya vraiment c j'ai pas trop quoi
dire de plus après la relation tina
norbert dragon's au bon bah c'est pareil
on s'est un peu ce qui va se passer et
puis on connaît un petit peu les
liaisons avec la entre les deux
personnages ont cédé certaines choses je
pas spoliés au cas où mais voilà on
connaît la suite on va dire cette saga
franchement elle me plaît beaucoup plus
qu harry potter on est vraiment un petit
peu dans une époque où la mode dans le
cinéma c'est de faire des prêts qu'elle
en fait je racontais le début du début
et cetera je pense que c'est star wars
comme je disais avec un pote
sylvain si tu passes par là un petit
coucou que je pense c'est star wars qui
a lancé le truc j'en parlais aussi et
mon père qui a lancé la mode un petit
peu des préquelles avec star wars 1 2 3
alors qu'on a commencé par quatre cinq
six un petit peu à l'envers quoi
puis après c'est pareil a eu le seigneur
des anneaux avec le hobbit
les x-men aussi on fait ça marvel
peut-être qu'ils le feront je suppose un
petit peu dans une prochaine vidéo j'en
parle pas plus et puis voilà j'aurai
tout le temps comme ça et puis il aida
c'est un peu pareil
et là ils font pareil etc harry potter
et je pense que c'est pour ça que la
ccam qui est beaucoup plus que ce que
vous lâcher
harry potter c'est un univers qu'on
commence à bien maîtriser c'est un rat
qu'on commence à bien connaître même
sans forcément lire les livres c'est mon
cas j'ai pas lui et oui je sais on t'a
moi oui n'insultez pas et je pense c'est
pour ça que j'apprécie encore plus à
l'aise et limo fantastique parce que je
repère vraiment beaucoup de détails jean
nicolas flamel et sert à envoyer sa
petite pierre philosophale dans dans son
petit le coffre et où c'était cool de le
voir je pense qu'il aura un rôle aussi
assez puissant et puis voilà le nord
j'ai vraiment kiffé j'ai rien à dire de
plus je suis très content très satisfait
je suis vraiment pressé d'être dans deux
ans pour connaître la suite
je vous donne rendez-vous dans ma
prochaine vidéo trois théories du coût
qui sera sur les crimes de grindelwald
animaux fantastiques j'essaie de sortir
ça dans la semaine vraiment le plus vite
je me donnais à fond qui t'a pas dormir
oui en attendant c'était argot rock que
le 'lion' alors soit avec vous n'hésitez
pas pardon à laisser un petit
commentaire avec ce que vous avez pensé
du film c'est important j'ai envie de
savoir ce que vous en avez pensé à me
suivre sur twitter c'est important où le
soutenir sur le type et puis bah voilà
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]